this is the recognition of the
Donetsk People's Republic by the Russian Federation for how long this
tragedy can continue
how long it can be
tolerated Russia has done everything to preserve the
territorial integrity of Ukraine all
these years persistently and patiently fought
for the implementation of the UN Security Council resolution
20 20 20 February 17, 15
On February 12, 15, in order to resolve the
situation in the Donbass, in this regard, I consider
it necessary to take a long overdue
decision to
immediately recognize the independence and
sovereignty of the Donetsk People's Republic
and the Lugansk People's Republic,
I ask the Federal Assembly of the Russian
Federation to support this decision and
then ratify the Treaty of Friendship and
Mutual Assistance with both  the two republics,
these documents will be prepared and
signed as soon as possible
[music]
[applause]